good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it how is the world
going to end
I'm glad we're starting on a light note
so for the last couple years I've been
thinking a lot about this weird reptile
species tuatara I've actually got a
tuatara on the wall back there one of
the things that gets me about tuatara is
that they've been on earth for over 150
million years humans meanwhile emerged
like maybe 300 thousand years ago so
we've been around for at most 0.2% of
tuatara history what I'm getting at is
that I kind of suspect that our world
may end a long time before the world as
for how I'm with TS Eliot on that when
not with a bang but with a whimper
so what's even the point of getting out
of bed okay I think the point of getting
out of bed is to seek a reason to get
out of bed and I know that's kind of a
recursive answer to your question but I
don't think we can expect like
fulfillment and meaning to like descend
upon us miraculously I think meaning is
something we make together and that's
what gets me out of bed in the morning
or at the latest in the early afternoon
now where did you write Turtles all the
way down mostly in dead now that I think
of it I'm not great at following my own
advice the Internet makes me feel worse
but I can't stop using it question mark
yeah yeah I do think there are some
pockets of the internet that make us
feel better but due to some issues with
the wiring of the human brain and also
the architecture of the social Internet
it is difficult at least for me to spend
a lot of time in those places I actually
have the same problem with food like I
could eat the stuff that makes me feel
good but some considerable portion of me
seems to want to not feel good that's
not really an answer to your question
it's just an expression of commiseration
are you still mad that pennies exist
I wouldn't say mad so much as
disappointed are you dreading or looking
forward to the book tour I am so looking
forward to it I can't even tell you how
much joy it brings me to be on tour with
Hank don't tell him I said that hey what
cities on the Turtles tour are sold out
or close to being sold out the shows in
Bellingham Chicago and Atlanta are sold
out I'm sorry that happened so quickly a
number of other places are closed so now
is a good time to get tickets here all
the cities we will be visiting more info
and tickets at Turtles all the way down
book.com link in the doobly-doo
is it rude if I come to your book tour
mostly to see Hank no why do you think
I'm going Balkans or Klingons for me
that's more of an and than an or Vulcans
and Klingon coffee or tea again I'm
gonna go with an
how do you feel about animals with no
necks oh no no no profoundly disturbing
undo undo if you could live in any time
besides this one what would it be
probably just the time like right before
I found out about the corner of the
Internet devoted to animals with no
necks
best hotdogs you ever consumed one time
in Reykjavik Iceland I went to this
hotdog stand and the hotdogs were like a
dollar and it wasn't just the best
hotdogs I've ever eaten it was like one
of the two or three best meals I've ever
eaten I know this wouldn't surprise
Freud but I literally sometimes dream
about that hotdog who's your least
favorite American founding father James
Wilkinson was like an actual secret
agent working against the United States
but even so I think you could make a
case for Aaron Burr his Turtles all the
way down gonna be translated into
Spanish and/or other languages yes in
fact here's the Spanish cover do you
ever feel like something you've finished
isn't good enough yes I feel that way
every Tuesday evening and then once
every three to six years when I publish
a new book like if you're writing a book
the goal is to use language to create an
experience inside of someone else's mind
right and I think there will always be
failures in that partly because of your
own insufficiencies you're always going
to run up against the limits of your
talent but also partly because of the
insufficiencies of language itself I
think it's the same with building
something in the physical world like
both the wood and the carpenter will
always have their imperfections so
inevitably all buildings will fall short
of the way they're initially imagined
but even so they can provide us shelter
Hank congratulations on a great VidCon
in Australia I hope you're getting some
rest because we go on tour in just 27
days but before then I will see you on
Friday